We will be using three different
text books in this course.
For the first mini course, we will be
using Python for Finance by Hilpish.
>> In the second mini course, we will be
using a book I wrote with Philip Romero
titled What Hedge Funds Really Do.
It's a thin book, but
it covers a lot of important material
that I think you will enjoy.
Finally, in the last mini course,
we will be using
Mitchell's Machine Learning.
>> The good news is if you're
taking the Machine Learning course,
you'll already have that book.
So you don't have to buy it again.
I also wanted to mention that we're not
going to cover all the material in these
books, so you don't need to
worry about being overwhelmed.